[Musique]
en fin de journée à saint pierre et
alain attend avec impatience le début
des 8e foulées solide aaron hill et le
responsable sportif de l'association des
handicapés du sud qui organise cette
manifestation pleine de sens
à bas le sport quoi c'est affreux belles
retrouvailles amicales ou vivre
l'harmonie rendra notamment à connaître
vraiment qu'on est vraiment con et six
ans la société que l'on peut partager
avec tout le monde même pas un handicap
mais je vais pas dire ça mais faire
comprendre nous valide la réalité des
personnes handicapées n'est pas chose
facile
exposer des véhicules de transport ont
fait partie est encore difficile à une
personne en situation de handicap d'être
transportés ne serait ce que pour aller
faire ses grosses c'est très compliqué
surtout si les personnes sont
dans les écarts dans des quartiers
éloignés actuellement la personne
elle-même finance le transport eux mais
par le biais du département par le biais
du mbba son sport et tu passes loisirs
moi je salue l'action de cette
association
j'aimerais que ça se fasse dans toute
l'île parce que là au moins on voit
vraiment le courage la dynamique des
personnes porteuses d'un handicap c'est
très important parce que moi qui
travaille avec tout le temps je peux
vous dire que ce sont des personnes qui
m'apporte beaucoup qui sont tolérants et
quand on voit les limites qu'ils peuvent
dépasser
on se pose des questions sur notre
propre personne ou les personnes valides
avant le départ tout le monde se regarde
derniers réglages et peu importe les
différences fâchent parce que son
fauteuil et plus longtemps qu'il est
désavantagé par à moi de lui dire ça
juste en avant la course by le sait de
toute façon j'ai vécu avec il le sait
mais bon filet avec ce qu'on a
on va peut être pas on n'y croit pas le
cas ça veut dire tout le monde partira
ensemble et on vivra en harmonie
[Musique]
j'ai envie de leur dire prenez du
plaisir et tous ensemble vous de
démontrer que la stricte solidarité est
là et que en même temps le sport est un
facteur de cohésion sociale
[Musique]
ces décotes plus dur ah ça fait mal ça
nous motive pour sortir montrer notre
différence et aussi la capacité
a évolué à avancer même si les écarts se
creusent que la route n'est pas
régulière pour son fauteuil le deuxième
tour alain et ses dalons ne lâche rien
[Musique]
donner l'exemple montré son courage dans
le sport si l'enthousiasmé le facteur de
réussite alors cette manifestation est
un succès
[Musique]
la maison des gens qui se sont fait ça
fait taire huitième année pour fait ça
et reste pas de recevoir bien qu'un jeu
avec nous bien dans le sourire
[Musique]